[Music]
congratulations first of all big
birthday over the weekend yeah I was 17
you turned 70 it's the news 69 how does
it feel kind of weird this one of those
weird numbers you know when I was 60 I
thought yeah 60 who cares 70 has a very
odd feel to it you know people are
phoning up seeing if you're okay people
a little worried about yeah yeah yeah
however you wouldn't be having a party
you'll be having a little rest you know
yeah creepy well how do you feel I feel
will not be I filled 37 that's good
[Applause]
you're a very youthful presence you're
very you know fun beautiful personality
I shouldn't be here at all I was in the
car today under way here I was born in
the middle of the war the Second World
War and then I became a welder when I
was 16 and I remember I was telling the
girl who came here with me today that
she's a manager to tour manager that I
used to weld in the double bottoms of
the ship you know which is about this
height with these deep penetration rods
where the thick thick fume yellow fumes
made my lips black and I'd stop to come
out and have a smoke
come on have a smoke and the guys doing
the pipes in the engine room it was
snowing asbestos women's Hey look at my
hair my [ __ ] I shouldn't be here
that's all right so I'm just delighted
to be here dude so you really it really
is true that it's it's it's how you feel
I mean you I think the fact you've been
in comedy and music for so long and it's
kept you young probably way younger
that's then people your voice the whole
thing is deeply overrated your age
acting your age is a bit as sensible as
acting your street number right there's
no sense to although that's kind of odd
things happen to you you have to pay
attention to like here sprouts what it
didn't grow before in your nose but but
like ferocious not just little hairs
you're talking like a woman oof yeah
Nolan your nose but I remember I swear
this is true one day I was leaning over
the wall shine base and I looked in the
mirror and there was a hair in the
forehead and the Marmon it must have
grown overnight through this world
overnight yeah I like a dr. Seuss
creature
I would have noticed if it was there the
night before you know when I was going
to bed I was surely I've seen a little
and I said to my wife look at that you
ain't on pulled it those girls are the
most used to trim my nose here once
every 27 years the Sun twice twice of
the three weeks now something just and
you have to wonder why not just blend it
in with your mustache you let it go and
give you get this kind of steady all my
stache overlapping the front one
and that was lying in bed thinking about
it I thought well your body doesn't do
things for nothing you know what there
must be a peony after you wonder what's
the purpose of long nasal hair to keep
things in it you know
tie them up and it's tool gathering I
don't know there's a purpose for it
somewhere and there's another thing
happens to use you to order involuntary
noises I don't I don't mean you know
that obvious huh yeah but suddenly one
day you'll lift something heavy the
previous day you just lifted and put it
over there when one day you lifted from
that day on that's the way is your
suitcase
[Applause]
yeah
[Applause]
like a caveman yeah there's no reason
for it whatsoever